hey everyone welcome to the latest
edition of just getting started i'm your
humble host rich eisen if you're new to
this podcast where you've been we've
already gotten three episodes under our
belts
with uh academy award winner matthew
mcconaughey
best-selling author and shark tank shark
damon john
creator of fubu and then uh last episode
soledad o'brien told us some great
stories about going from
small market television to cnn to
being a business owner herself and
you know the the whole idea of this
podcast
is to make sure if there's anybody out
there
that is wondering about the direction of
their lives if it's been turned upside
down for the pandemic or you feel that
you need to pivot or you need to start
on something or you have an idea
and you're kind of wondering how to just
get started on it
well the origin stories of all the
people that i'm going to have on this
show hopefully
we'll give you something portable
something for you to take
and implement in your own lives to try
and start down that path for you to
succeed
for you to go ahead and realize an idea
and
hopefully a dream and my
guest on today's show is one of the most
prolific novelists of all time
he's harlan cobin and his origin story
is phenomenal and i can't wait to just
get started
on this podcast so let's do it
and joining me here on just getting
started is a man with
75 million books in print including
win which uh came out on march
16th he is harlan cobin how are you sir
rich great to be here how's it going
what a pleasure to have you here on this
show
what a pleasure um and the amount of
pleasure that you've given
me and so many others um through your
riding
and your storytelling uh on behalf of
them i really appreciate you doing this
show
so thanks wow but i i'm ready to leave
now that's good enough
yeah i know that's a walk-off that's one
of those that's usually walk off and as
i was saying i thought maybe i should
close with that but you know what i i
just uh i like telling people whose work
i enjoy
exactly how i feel right now right off
the bat uh but let's
let's let's start with how you you got
started
harlan when did you first know that you
wanted to write
and and create that well first i think
this is a
different maybe for most writers or
maybe not but usually when you hear this
question i've been on so many panels
where
uh there's always the writer who says i
always knew
i was gonna be a writer when i was a
four-month-old
fetus a pen formed in my mother's womb
and i scratched out several sonatas
while
doing and then they always like when i
was five years old the children
gathered around me in the playground as
they told them
pirate tales of whoa i
got beaten up in my neighborhood for
that and i grew up in a jewish
neighborhood it wasn't a tough
neighborhood
um so i came to it later i was in
college
at amherst college and i worked a summer
in the costa del sol of spain as a
watching american tourists not because
i'm a brilliant linguist but because
my grandfather on the travel agency it
was nepotism
plain and simple yes but um you know
this is the early to mid 80s and
americans on vacation i was sort of
watching them were
acting so bizarrely they'd be like very
frightened of travel
is all the cliches american and i said
wow
someone should write a book about it and
i did i came back my senior year of
college
i tried getting a professor let me do it
as a thesis but that didn't go over and
i just did it i sat
in my room at college and i wrote an
entire novel and it was
um crap it was pompous and self-absorbed
and pretentious and all the things
that a first novel is but then i got the
writing bug from that
um like a virus and i started to write
what i loved
which uh you know you can call mystery
crime thriller i call it the novel of
immersion the book you take on vacation
but you'd rather stay at home
um because you know you want to stay in
your room just because
you have to know what happens to wynn
and myron and all the rest of the people
yeah and and before we i guess delve
into that a little bit
let me linger on on the start here
so your grandfather owned
a travel agency and i guess to make
some coin to get started in a way
in college in amherst you decided to
take a get what what are you
what do you mean you were watching
people on vacation what is what
what sort of gig is that harlan i mean
it's sort of
do you remember i mean i guess it still
goes on but they were these kind of
american bus tours
sure and so a group of 50 would fly in
and my job was to watch them when they
were in across the del sol of spain so
i'd pick them up at the airport
and i would tour them around and i was
much too young and really stupid and
didn't know what i was doing
so like we would travel remember we
would take this eight hour bus ride to
granada
and this is how americans were on
vacation so they would go to me
you know harlan like two hours ago i was
looking through my binoculars and i saw
this small white church
way in the distance what was the name of
that church i'd expect you to know and i
would just make it up because you know
iglesia de la muerto which means church
of lunch you know
anything just that would please them um
and so the experience is kind of like
wow these people are
really acting strangely while they're on
vacation they're very nervous and i
thought it'd be cool
to write a book about this hotshot tour
guide
and his um humorous clients but of
course that didn't really work out
that's why i was
pompous and pretentious and and
self-absorbed which a lot of first
novels are well i mean i
i remember those tours because uh you
know you and i are somewhat similar uh
where you uh you know you're a newark
native right but now you're in
livingston right so
that's exit 14 on the turnpike i was
exit 13 from staten island across the
goethals bridge on the other side
and my dad was a french teacher and he
took his french class
uh on tour on tours in paris and quebec
and i remember these tours
they would come with like their own tote
bags and things like that
oh yeah so i i know what you're talking
about
um and so you're if i had told
if i could go back in a time machine
harlan cobin right now and told that
kid who is pointing out what church
might have been on
on the horizon on their
tour uh that you would be a world-class
novel novelist with novels
all over the globe and television shows
and films based on these novels all over
the globe literally
you know i i would have to explain to
you what netflix poland was at the time
but
you know if if i had told you that's
what you would become what would you
have said
wouldn't have believed it um you know
it's interesting because you know you
talk about having goals in your life
whatever else when i was young
i played college basketball division
three i was a jewish all-american i
don't want to brag
i was a jewish all-american they found
five jews who played college basketball
that year and and made a team it was
me heshi and moishin two guys from
yeshiva i think um
back then but when i was young that was
my dream was i would one day be in nba
basketball player but as a writer my
dreams were always
extraordinarily modest and incremental
so you know my dream originally was if i
could just have one novel published just
one time
have a novel published maybe one time
walk past a bookstore
and see the book there that would be it
that's that's all i would need and then
it's like
well i could just have two two novels
published just to prove it wasn't a
fluke
well if i could just scratch out a
living doesn't be a good living
just enough that i could do this well
maybe i just scratched the bottom of the
new york times bestsellers one time for
one week so
you know it went up incrementally you
know eventually like oh can i get number
one on the list
um and i think that was the smart way of
going about it so i enjoyed sort of
every stage
staying ambitious but also staying
satisfied
that can't be easy to do though right
staying ambitious but staying satisfied
that's
sort of a unique way to live in the
moment while you're feeling the pressure
to continue uh succeeding
and also coming up with ideas that are
fresh i mean that that that can't be
simple harlan where do you think you got
that from well how do you do that
well first of all i i think i came up
you know my first book came out in 1990
my first new york times bestseller was
2001. so it was 11 years later so it
wasn't overnight it was 10 books
um but part of it was in those days this
is sort of before
amazon and really the internet um
i was too dumb to know how low level i
was you know
i didn't have an amazon ranking to check
i didn't have anything compared to so i
thought
i was still the cat's ass even though i
wasn't doing if i had realized what a
pimple on the buttocks
of publishing i was i probably would
have lost my mind
and gotten discouraged but you know i
had a book in the store
and then i was a paperback original
author but with dell which is a big name
in a big house and
i wasn't making any money but i thought
you know this is this is kind of cool
and how it goes and i didn't really
it's one of the reasons i tell people
stay off the internet and stop checking
your rankings and all that
stuff that naivete i think really helped
me stay focused and the other thing is i
have nothing else
in my life rich i mean um i have my
family
and i have and i have the books it's not
like you know i'm i collect i i don't
cook i don't do
i don't have a hobby i don't collect i
don't know
vases or whatever it is this is all i
have
so that fear frankly um that i would i
would have to find a real job or
something like that is a motivating
factor i mean i know it's in your case
too rich
right i mean how much is the fear you
have to one day wake up and do something
that you don't love for a living keep
you doing what you're doing well it's
funny
you know harlan before you popped on i
was chatting with
some of uh my fantastic producers of
this podcast and they were asking me
some questions about
you know that the taping of this is
going on in free agency and
actually on the day in which wynn is
coming out your 33rd
book and they asked me like are you sick
and tired of talking about sports and
i'll say i just
tilted my camera up i'm like no there's
the roof that's over my head thank you
you know thankfully i get to talk about
that stuff i live in the toy department
you know
and yeah i wouldn't say there's any fear
um but there is a singular
desire to stay you know
current and also
to be honest since you're you know
you've been brutally honest so far too
to to to be somebody that i want people
to spend
time with you know like i'm talking on
this podcast i do i talk three hours a
day on my show i
fortunate to have nfl network you know
if you don't want to spend time with me
you know if i'm an [ __ ] you know why
why
so i'm i'm trying to um just
be myself best i can and just believe in
what i'm doing
but i find it fascinating of you saying
in a way
that technology will deny you the
ignorance is bliss
way of just ignoring all the noise and
what your rankings might be
just keep your head down and keep
putting out the product that you believe
in that you think is
quality right i mean did i get that
right yeah
i mean yeah it's that's exactly right
there's also it's a strange thing when
you're a writer because you have
both you're crippled with anxiety
and insecurity and self-doubts you know
i suck i'm not good at this
the imposter syndrome while at the same
time
you have the hubris to think i'm gonna
write something
and talk to you straight for 400 pages
and you're going to pay me
to to have that to have the joy of
listening to me right
and that's a complete contradiction and
yet every writer who
produces pages that i know feels that
saint the same way
so it's a it's a it's something you kind
of have to battle it
through every day if you have a writer
on your show who thinks he's good
i guarantee you they suck only bad
writers think they're good
uh so that's part of what what
fuels me uh this the idea that you know
if i
if i if i if i run out of ideas i'm
going to have to now
work at a pharmacy and sell pens and you
know
have a real job and i'm not i'm not
qualified to do anything else
this is all i can do so um who was the
one who told you your first manuscript
just to circle back to that wasn't any
good or you
you knew it yourself or just the fact
that uh it didn't sell
or anything like that so how did how did
you
glean that your first attempt at
becoming a novelist wasn't up to
par oh well you know it's a number of
rejections and then
as time goes on you start to be able to
look at your work
more critically sometimes in a negative
way that's not
fair to you also i mean a lot of people
will
i don't like to read my old books and
the comparison
i make is do you remember there was that
essay you wrote in college you thought
was brilliant
right and you and you find it now and
you read and go wow how did i even pass
this course
right because it's not that's bad you
see all the seams and you don't like
yourself
20 years ago or 30 years ago or however
long it's the same thing with books you
know when i'm doing these netflix
adaptations i
was recently reading one that was you
know almost 20 years old and i'm like
wow you know this kind of sucks and then
okay it's all right
it's got a certain energy but you're
very hard on your old stuff i think
that's just again
part of the of the process that that
makes you right
did you ever get the rejection and
think that you're on the wrong path did
that ever happen to you
you know i i i was so practical i was
working the whole time i was writing
so it was never i never dreamt that i
would make a living
i really didn't i hoped to be a guy who
had a book in a store
and could say i was a published novel
novelist while working full-time for
whatever else i was going to do i was
very practical about the whole thing i
did not
you know and i don't recommend it by the
way i don't recommend
those who want to write that are
listening to us right now quit your job
most writers that i know most successful
writers
were working at the time that their
first novel or two or even
three were published if it takes you 12
months to write a novel if you have all
the time in the world
it shouldn't take you more than 13 or 14
months if you're still
working full time it's the goldfish bowl
effect
of writing so i was more practical about
it i think
than a dreamer which is kind of unusual
for
for me but it worked so the and the job
that you had while you were
just getting started was the travel
agency gig
that your grandfather had owned yeah
from 84 when i graduated college until
1992.
uh that's what i did eight years damn
and is it true that dan brown went to
amherst with you too that you were
that you were were you roommates did
that actually we were we were in the
same fraternity
uh they got rid of fraternities in 84
about
the last year by coincidence the year i
graduated
um they got rid of dan and i were
fraternity brothers so
while i may have sold all those books
you were saying i'm not even the number
one best-selling mother
of my own fraternity at america at small
little amherst college at the time
is any of the sadistic stuff in the da
vinci code born out of hazing from that
parliament not no it was extraordinary
our fraternities um
back then don't ask me how we're
actually which is kind of modern we had
women in our
they were co-ed fraternities because
amherst had been all men
and when they admitted women they they
were some kind of suit
women had to be members of fraternity so
they were extraordinarily mellow
fraternities there was no hazing or
anything like that it was more like a
social club
my fraternity brother it's your
fraternity father and your fraternity
sister or sorority brother i don't even
yeah my gosh that is a pretty wild
so okay so then when you you started
the myron bolitar series
now um that was
based on what trying to combine some of
what you
knew from your desire to be
a basketball player or your hopes and
then combining it with your
obvious at the time current ability to
write and pen some fascinating stories
is that
basically what it's born out of harlan
yeah i had written two standalone novels
before that um
both of which were published to no
greater claim or sales
okay um and then my agent at the time
actually came up with the idea at the
time this is why also the other rules
don't
follow trends unless you really believe
in them but my agent at the time
thought a sports oriented mystery
involving
a lead that was female at the time sue
grafton was coming up in saraporetsky
and i went home thinking about that and
i was like i really you know i i don't
think i can have a series right now i'm
not good enough yet to write a series
the lead character who is
female i've done it since but not back
in those days
and myron was just there i uh myron
bolator who's my
series hero he was me with a lot of wish
fulfillment writers don't like to would
admit that but he you know i played
college basketball he's a lot better
he's funnier he's smarter he's stronger
he's uh you know better with the line
better with the fist um i haven't beaten
two areas i'm a better dancer i'll
demonstrate later
and i'm slightly wiser in the ways of
women this is no great shakes we're
talking about like gonorrhea being
better than syphilis we're not talking
about two geniuses here
but i'm you know slightly wiser in the
ways of women i've had
my wife that has been with me for a long
time and myron's love life for the most
part has been a disaster
um so that was sort of how uh the series
began
okay and then obviously when the series
takes off and it becomes immensely
successful
was there uh any concern that
for you or you felt like
you had to try something else or was
there a concern
by doing something else certainly since
as you just pointed out your first two
attempts at something else before it
um wasn't as successful as you wanted
was there any
self-doubt there after you had obviously
already hit it
with this idea harlan well myron
actually didn't hit it
um so the first four myrons were all
paper they called paperback originals
that's when they come
out mass market paperback and because
we're being completely
honest and open with each other please
my first myron book
i received an advance of five thousand
dollars damn
by the time my fourth came out and i
don't want to brag on the air
i was up to six thousand dollars
overnight success i used to be
embarrassed to talk about money for one
reason now embarrass talk about money
for the other reason but you know i
don't really don't like to admit that
very often but what the heck
we're trying to give people inspiration
here yeah
so um what i tried to do when i wrote
myron is i loved the classic detective
the raymond chandler robert b parker
kind of detective but what i thought was
lacking there a little bit
was there they didn't have the plots
that were twisty enough that had the
twist endings which i could do with the
standalones
i was trying to combine those those two
worlds
and after seven myron books and the
growth was sort of
nice and slow but it reached the stage
where the eighth was not going to be a
huge breakout no matter what because
barnes and noble or whoever it was at
the time that was big looks in their
computer and they say well you sold x
amount then x plus two
x plus four we're not going to order
four times x for
your new book and push it and i had this
idea
about a man and a woman who were happily
married the wife is murdered
eight years past he can't get over her
death he gets an email
he clicks an uh hyperlink and he sees
his dead wife walk by
on a street cam and i love this idea
myron couldn't tell it
so i wrote a book called tell no one and
that was my breakout book that book
sold more than the other seven myrons
times 10.
that was the first new york times
bestseller and what changed my life
and that changed your life what how did
that feel
i mean how did that feel for you it was
you know it was great
i mean let's face it it was great but
here's the thing i was
um 39 my fourth child
was born the day that i hit the new york
times bestseller
i always remember it's july 11 2001 so
i was at least you know i i was steady
in my life i was married i had four kids
all over the age of seven
i couldn't go nuts um but any kind of
success like that
really does mess with your head there's
just no question about it so when i see
these young athletes
or these young rock stars or these young
actors that all of a sudden are hit with
tremendous fame which
no writer gets that kind of thing we get
something but not like that
um it's a wonder any of them survive uh
it really will turn your head and mess
with your head it's hard to write after
that
um you start second-guessing yourself is
the next book going to be as good
and all that um so yeah
it was great and it's been great it
changed my life and all
positive that's something to be wary of
it really was
and i think you know to try and uh
you know touch upon
a little bit more there harlan it's just
that i i find
many people are sometimes a little
because of what you just said
i i'm afraid maybe too strong of a word
wary
of success and thus don't even try
that what happens if you know this
does work what next what will be next i
don't even know what's
i don't even know how to make this work
to begin with
so why even try because i don't even
know what the hell's going to happen
next i i genuinely think i've run into a
lot of people i sometimes have to fight
through that myself
so hearing you say that kind of makes me
pause right there
you know i mean you i'm sure in your
career
you had that moment when you were going
from a sort of smooth
line and then you just jumped up a lot i
mean there was a moment in your life in
your career
too so did you have those same sort of
uh
oh god yeah i was in small market tv you
know just
i guess uh dovetail a little bit what
you said i was in reading california
which is like market
130 out of 205 metered markets
and my not to brag um
my starting uh salary was 6.75 an hour
and i worked there for three months my
news director calls me in
sits me down this is krcrtv the abc
affiliate known as the spirit of the
north state was the phrase of the
of the tv station harlan and i sat down
he calls me in and he tells me that my
probation period is over
had no idea i was on probation it was
like an animal house it was secret
probation
without the double and he he slides
across the table
a folded up piece of paper that was
stapled at the top
so opening it up took a little bit of
sort of like an envelope please type yes
there was a yes there was a little bit
of drama and oh i had no idea what it
was and it was a piece of paper
congratulating me on my raise not to
brag again
from 6.75 to 6.95 an hour
did you spend that all in one place oh
man i went out and i bought a snickers
you know it was phenomenal you know
just amazing but that's where i went
from
sending a tape to a headhunter saying
you know i left my resume
in the copy machine that was not a good
day in my career
uh when my news director found it and
left it on my desk with a post-it note
to say you left this in the copy machine
and uh i sent a tape to a headhunter and
espn saw it and i was on sportscenter by
age 26.
right literally like that and then all
of a sudden every single person who i
was
uh idolizing to be honest and who
i was emulating on the air which is
another
phrase of ripping off you know as we do
in our business
suddenly they're my colleagues i'm
looking around the newsroom and i'm
wondering do i belong here
you know right i mean i i went through
all that
all right first of all as a as a as a
fiction writer novelist
i'm trying to get in the head of this
guy who sits there going how can i build
up this giving
an extra 15 cents a week an hour too i'm
gonna take the paper
and fold it where's my stapler i need my
stapler so we have the dramatic moment
of him opening you're welcome harlow
you're welcome it's gonna be
it's gonna be your 34th novel is gonna
be dynamite man
and you know when i was in high school
bob lee would did my games
sure he's mr new jersey new jersey three
suburban tv
when i was in when i was in high school
from 76 to 1980
bob lee did our games he was a skinny
guy with the big glasses
and that was who did the games not to
throw out not to get off track it's all
good
but that's it but so it's the same it is
the same kind of a thing so
um but it's all good i mean i was on
another panel
i always loved talking about things
writers say that drive me crazy and we
were asked on a panel it's like
um you know what's the downside of being
a best-selling author and the answer is
nothing i mean this is the sweetest gig
imaginable being a best-selling author
and we don't deal because we you know
the same way you have
you know we both know a lot of people
who are famous and the downside of that
there's not much downside if i put a hat
on no one recognizes me anywhere that i
go
so it's not like it's a problem um so
it's really a great so i don't want to
make it sound like i'm at all saying
what was me it's been
it's the sweetest gig in the world no i
know but
but any any you know there's an origin
story and that's part of the reason why
i want to do this that there's always
doubts there's always doors slammed
closed
and then it's and it always does uh
provide a through line
that uh that that never leaves you and i
think hopefully for many people out
there could be replicated certainly in a
time
like this i just want to take a quick
break and be right back with the here
and now with harlan coven right here on
just getting started
i want to pause on this episode of just
getting started for a brief moment to
tell you about
some of my sponsors who have made this
episode of just getting started
possible including my friends at grove
collaborative we all know
going to the store these days can be an
entirely stressful venture there's
nothing worse than
forgetting something on your list
needing to make multiple trips right
so shopping for home essentials should
be easy and convenient and that's where
grove collaborative comes in
grove is the online marketplace that
delivers healthy home
beauty and personal care products
directly to you
with grove you don't have to shop
multiple stores or search endlessly
online to get all the natural goods you
need for you and your family plus
shipping is fast and free on your first
order join over two million households
who have made grove collaborative their
trusted spot to make their homes happier
and healthier making the switch to
natural products has never been easier
folks for a limited time when my
listeners go to grove.co
eisen you'll get to choose a free gift
with your first order of
thirty dollars or more but you have to
use my special code
go to grove dot co slash eisen to get
your exclusive offer
that's grove dot co slash eisen
now let's talk a little bit about my
friends at sleep number
my sleep number setting is 60 my wife's
is 70. just 10 numbers apart but let me
tell you
it makes the world of difference and
it's so great to have a bed
where you can set your side of the bed
to just how firm or soft you want it to
be
and your spouse or your partner can do
the same on their side of the bed it's
amazing
when we devote small moments throughout
the day to recharging we set ourselves
up to get the quality sleep we need
as well so you need to take micro steps
throughout the day before you even go to
sleep
to help yourself out like setting a
daily caffeine cut off and schedule time
to go outside to take a walk in sunshine
block time on your calendar to move
around people it couldn't be more
important to do all of that before you
get into your sleep number bed and set
your sleep number setting
to exactly how you want to sleep proven
quality sleep is life-changing sleep
introducing the new sleep number 360 c4
smart bed
and the queens now only at 14.99 the
queen
is now only 14.99 only at sleep number
stores or sleep number dot com
slash eisen now let's get back to harlan
cobin
okay harlan uh let's talk about the here
and now win
your 33rd book and
obviously uh fans are excited to get any
book from you
but to have a character from the myron
bolitar series and and sort of
pull back the curtain here what what why
why'd you
decide to go in this direction for for
this book
harlow well wynn has been um you know i
always love sidekicks i mean
you know from sherlock holmes to watson
to batman and robin
i even like running scared with billy
crystal and gregory hunt
i love buddy buddy yeah i love any of
that kind of thing going on
uh so when was myron's um sidekick and
he's
super rich blue blood uh sociopathic
um dangerous
guy who is also a member of marion pine
valley
and you know those great great golf
courses and lives in this kind of dual
world
and i always think with sidekicks less
is more i think the reason people love
loved win was i you don't want too much
of them
but suddenly an idea came and i said wow
i want to try letting wind tell this
story
and it was really actually almost too
easy to get into his skin
um i wonder what's part of me um has the
he's not he's not necessarily likeable
guys love him but he's not necessarily
likable he he's dangerous he he's a
vigilante
he goes too far but this is
what you're talking about you know it's
in your case
it's not just being likable i have to
want to hang with you rich i mean for
your job to be successful
you have to be the guy that if i'm at a
pub to talk in british terms
and i'm listening in or i want to sit
with somebody i want to listen to them
doesn't mean they're nice they don't be
nice guys
they have to be interesting and
intriguing and i i hope win is that
well and then you know i i think fans
are
yeah do you want to get the whole band
back together my brother-in-law scott is
easily the biggest harlan colbin fan
that i know
so i called him up i'm like hey i'm
going to talk to your guy today like
what do you want to know
and he's like ask him when you're going
to do another
myron bolitar book and get the whole
band back together is this sort of a
gateway
to that this book harlan or you're done
i don't know i mean man plans god laughs
as uh myron often quotes the old
expression i love that one
when i read a book um i put everything
into that particular
book if i had even a scrap of a good
idea it somehow
ends up in that book and when i finish
it it's like i just got i
just went 15 rounds in a heavyweight
fight and i can't even lift my arms
there will be no rematch howard no moss
i will never do it again
i'm exhausted i'm not like thinking
three books ahead i just i can't do it
so you know people have been writing me
thinking myron was
when we're done they're not um this is
sort of proof
my guess is myron will be back the whole
gang will be back it might be from
wynn's viewpoint it might be from
myron's viewpoint but i really don't
know it's not
the book i'm writing next um but it
might be it might be the one after that
i just
i can't predict you're already on book
34.
you're already doing that yeah it's due
pretty soon it comes out
every march i come out so i try to
finish them around june or july
so when the pandemic hit a year ago i
was about
halfway through or a third of the way
through win so
i'm about halfway or a third of the way
through the next book which is a sequel
to two different books uh
one i wrote called the boy from the
woods and one some of people might be
familiar with called the stranger which
was on netflix as a
as a tv series and i didn't plan on on a
stranger being involved in this book at
all
but around page 50 all of a sudden the
stranger just popped in
so now the stranger is part of the story
do you ever again
again i like going back to the part of
in our podcast earlier i was asked do i
ever get tired of
talking sports and i'm like no i mean i
i love it and you know
thank you know knock on wood it puts a
roof over my head do you ever just
want to tap out and say i don't want to
write a book this year i don't want to
wanna
you know i wanna do x y and z i know you
said that you don't have any hobbies or
anything
outside of that but do you ever sit
there and go like again do i gotta come
up with another idea again does that
ever hit you
at all sure but that's part that's just
part of the process i know that if i
didn't do it
you know part of like part of life is
balance right so
you know you're balancing with your your
spouse or your partner balance with your
family balance with your eating balance
with your exercise
all those things if i'm not writing my
life is out of balance doesn't matter
how good those other things are
if i'm not writing well that balance
teeters
that's just part of my makeup so i need
to write even if i'm on vacation
it's not because i don't like to relax
i'm the best relaxer in the world this
is a great job for somebody who's fairly
lazy
and doesn't get out very much but if i
don't wake up in the morning before the
kids will wake up on vacation
and if you have college-age kids you
know that you know if you wake up at 7
00 a.m you have six hours to write
before they wake up
if i don't write i just am not happy i'm
not i'm not where i
should be so part of it is my makeup
part of it i think is the
is the is the work ethic that i was
raised with
where you have to make it like a job i
don't know if it is a job
but a plumber can't one day wake up and
say oh today i can't do pipes i just
can't i
just can't do pipes i i feel the same
way i beat myself up a lot
if i'm acting the artiste right well i
guess if you're your own boss
and you can make your own hours and then
from again
what i've read in preparation for this
you can make your own office like say a
starbucks
you know like um that could be difficult
to not have the discipline
right to actually conduct the job
i would imagine yeah yeah i'm not a very
disciplined person and too many other
things but in this i'm disciplined i i
need to get it done or i just don't feel
right
my life is somewhat out of balance okay
and is it true again that you you do
work in coffee shops i can't imagine
that you have
uh the concentration level to
to do that sort of like i i'd want to be
you know
in in a tank where nobody's talking
you're not hearing the grinding of beans
you know the misspelling of names on the
side of a cup which always happens at a
starbucks
i'd love to see how many times there
harlan has been attempted on the side of
your ground
i actually i could just say bob and i go
i'm like what
harlow just bob bob my name is bob okay
and you can spell it backwards i don't
care
honestly cobin harley copeland with an
eye i'm sure there's been it's been
botched but
how so how how do you how do you do that
i'm a mood writer so sometimes i like
the noise
um white noise makes me focus more so
um i actually there'll be times when i'm
when i'm in a coffee shop and it will be
noisy whatever else and all of a sudden
i'll realize like an hour or two hours
have passed and i haven't moved and
people have walked by me and they've
jostled me
and maybe somebody sat across from me
because there was no other seat
available and that's like the greatest
kind of moments but
um yeah i can focus noise doesn't bother
me
um i just i need to be left alone i
don't like it
if somebody's trying to talk to me or
sometimes somebody will know who i am
when i'm in a coffee shop
and they'll be staring at me and
pretending they're not my dude let's
just come over and say hi to each other
and then move on because
it's that surreptitious look that's
distracting me and i look up and you
look away
just say let's just say hi to one
another and then move on with our lives
but outside of that so and i change up
um
it's like i say it's like riding a horse
and i ride it really hard until the
horse just drops dead and then i look
for another horse
so i'll change places all the time i'll
change how i do it
sometimes trains planes automobiles
whatever it is that's working i will do
that
until it stops working mostly now a
morning writer i used to be a night
writer when i was younger
um but if that you know whatever's
working i just try to do
okay uh in the few minutes i have left
with you here then um
let me use some of this real estate on
uh on the sports world
so you're from jersey does that make you
a giant a jet nick
what are you a ranger oh i do i do cheer
on for some reason both the giants and
the jets okay um but i i'm a giants fan
i've been i'm a giants guy in fact this
morning i was interviewed by my old pal
michael strahan
who uh who i've known for a number of
years um
you know on gma now i'm so proud well
he's coming
he's going to come on this podcast in
the summer i mean literally
what he has done from small school to
hall of fame
and then from playing career to let's be
honest like the dick clark of his
generation
literally 100 000 pyramid host as well
as good morning america
and everything else it really is
beyond remarkable and inspirational
what's that i tease them that'll show up
at the opening of a garage door i mean
it's unbelievable how hard that
that guy works but you know it's
interesting i golf with mike
michael every once in a while okay and
he's of course the nicest guy in the
world and everything else but you can
sometimes
see and you talk about like other
athletes if he sees a football player
who he feels has talent and is not
trying hard competition
he really yeah he's a such a competitive
guy in a healthy way
right it's really something i mean
that's that's something i almost want to
figure it out and bottle it because he's
ridiculously competitive but not
at all in a nasty way um and you start
seeing that every once in a while when
he talks about
athletes he thinks have the talent and
aren't doing it he has
no patience for that because he just
doesn't get how
you're not working your hardest to be a
great whatever it is
and he's and he's gotten better as a
broadcaster right he's
he gets better and better so you know um
i'm a giants fan i'm a new york rangers
fan
okay um yankees my last game i was at
was march
6th of last year i was at the rangers
game when they won
overtime uh six to five and uh
that was my last i got a picture on my
uh
instagram of me going like this as the
game ends against the glass
um after the goal is scored so i know
even though i'm a basketball player i
don't really like going to basketball
but
you know the knicks have i've tried to
make the knicks my team it's been
been not easy the last 20 years
sure that's not no
the mere mention of the owner james
dolan on my daily show every day my
my uh my fellow compatriots say that i
go down a dolan wormhole i could just
get sucked into
just being so iratis to the way he you
know ejects oakley from madison square
garden and
sticks his face in the team a little bit
too much and you know
but i don't want to go down that
wormhole with you here are you a yankee
or a met
uh well or neither there again for some
reason i grew up as a
don't ask me why um i was a houston
astros fan
so now i i cheer on both but as i've
gotten older i've moved away from that i
trump both the yankees
and the mets okay and i don't i don't
care as much as i used to
you know i'll tell you i was an astros
fan when they lost to the mets
in 86. mike scott famous that was a hell
of a series that nlcs
so i went to shea stadium when mike
scott pitched wearing a houston astros
jacket and sitting in the bleachers oh
my god i'm alive today
dickie thon hits the game winning home
run vicki thon and alan ashby
both hit home runs that game while the
mets were whining about mike scott
scuffing the balls and i'm wearing it
i'll never forget
when they hit the home run i'm standing
i went with two yankee fans of course
hated the mets
and the entire place is sound and the
three of us are standing up cheering
and i don't know how i walked out of
that ballpark alive
to this day and now i love the mets so
it's a it's a it's a funny
but my point was when the astros lost
that series
i fell into a funk now we have a lot of
people out there i really fell into a
funk and then i said to myself
what the hell are you doing caring so
much and i've never let myself care that
much again
well thank god that you survived it i
mean your entire success your family or
everybody that could have been just uh
they could have all been derailed that
night that dicky thon went yard
and that didn't happen a lot but dickie
thon and alan ashby went yard it wasn't
it wasn't the guys you expected that
year so let's let's finish up with a
question that i know
um you probably don't have an answer to
but heck with it i'll
ask it anyway certainly since it's not
about volume it's about quality
you got 33 books out you're already
working on 34 you know
there's going to be more is there a
number in your mind 50
is that a round number or something like
that or or is there a number
in in your mind that you want to hit or
anything like that
no i i just i want to write as well as i
think as long as i think i'm still doing
it as well as i
possibly can the tv stuff which i've
done a lot the last few years
has been a welcome distraction i thought
it would slow down my pace a little bit
but
weirdly enough it works the opposite
because i'm i'm a socially adept
introvert right so i'm in this room but
then every once in a while i like to get
out and go on the set and i'm on the set
for two days i want to kill myself and i
come right back and i start to write
harder
so they actually work um well together
they work in conjunction with one
another not
and they're not taking away from one
another right now but i don't have a set
number there'll be a time i'm sure
when i'll start you know but it's one of
the great things too i worry about
athletes like
you know i'm 59 and i can still be in my
prime doing this
if someone had told me when i was you
know 38 i'd be starting to go on the
downside of doing this
you know way it is for an athlete um i i
get that pain it's
something i write about a lot in the
books that pain of an athlete's light
dimming um i hope someday i guess
that'll happen to me but
not yet instead you're the tom brady of
novelists harlow
you're going strong and so lastly what
piece of advice
what piece of advice would you give
somebody who is thinking right now
about you know what yeah uh harlan cobin
went from
you know conducting tours uh for his
grandfather's
uh travel agency and he's like i'm gonna
i'm i'm gonna somebody said you should
write a book you know what i'm gonna
do it and um and even though that
manuscript didn't amount to anything um
now look at you where you are what
advice would you give somebody
about about starting right now
well two things one is more direct if
you're trying to write you have you have
to write
um doesn't matter if it's crap turn off
that that voice in your head that that
hates what you're writing
you can always fix bad pages you can't
fix
no pages right so make sure you get
something down
and then you can always improve on it
it's like diamond mining you grab
something ugly out of the ground but
that's what's valuable
and then you shine it up and make it
something um
worth selling the other thing is
perseverance
most guys just quit after a little bit a
little while
you do need luck i'm not going to
pretend otherwise it's true of anything
you have in luck
in life you do need some luck but with
more perseverance you have
the more luck you have so those are the
two things i guess i would tell somebody
harlan cobin this was uh as as great as
i was hoping it would be
a lot of we know a lot of people in
common they're they're they're
they said you're you guys are going to
hit it off and i'm i'm i'd love to do
this more often
and anytime you'd want to you know
promote
anything obviously you got a lot of
stuff going on i'd be more than happy to
give you my platform and just uh
and just chit chat so congratulations
this has been i've been i've been
i've been a fan for a long time rich so
this has been real honor thank you so
much
appreciate you saying that thank you
when is available where all books are
sold
harlan cobin here on just getting
started
well that was great uh i got to tell you
i i i was told that i would love the guy
and
i feel like i'm i'm uh i'm thick as
thieves right now
and um i hope you enjoyed hearing what
he had to say if there's anybody out
there that you know that's got a
manuscript or is thinking about trying
to start on one or
what they should do if they're stuck in
writer's block or they've tried it
a couple of times and they don't think
they've got the hang of it or will ever
get the hang of it you tell them
that harlan cobin tried twice and struck
out
and then got a new idea and tried five
more times
before he actually hit it big 11 years
if i did the actual math
between him starting to write his first
book and then finally getting on the new
york times bestseller list
11 years for him to sit there and think
was he on the right path was he doing
the right thing
and he kept at it you know and that's
part of my concern a little bit about
the concept of this podcast even though
i deep down feel like this is the right
thing to do and for me to do
and even though there's so much negative
crap out there in the world today me
talking positivity does that rate
will that actually gain some traction do
people want to actually
argue as opposed to agree in this
polarized world and
part of my concern is then also putting
a podcast out of positivity where
sometimes the actual piece of advice is
stick to it
and you know that everybody knows that
deep down that you can't give up don't
quit don't have to quit in you don't
ever
want to stop and stick to it and that's
the piece of advice that you take from
it but sometimes you need to hear it
from somebody that you think is so
successful that they started uh
hitting the level of success that they
have right from the get-go and that's
why i want to choose origin stories
that's why i want to continue to talk
about these origin stories
because harlan colbin started and he
tried and it didn't work out
and he kept at it and then it worked out
and even
with all that he sometimes sits there
and wonders if what he's doing is the
right thing to do
so please take that into account if
you're sitting there wondering if you're
doing the right thing or if it hasn't
worked out so far or you've been trying
it you feel like you've been banging
your head against the wall
keep at it keep at it because
you never know what's right around the
corner and what's right around the
corner on next week's edition
of just getting started my scheduled
guest
is none other than dr anthony fauci
we'll talk about his origin story and
then obviously the here and now could
not be more relevant
to all of us so i want to thank
everybody for taking in this edition of
just getting started
and i want to thank my executive
producer lou pellegrino i want to thank
my coordinating producer
uh zach rosenfield i want to thank also
robert barowski associate producer and
engineer sarah mccrory associate
producer
and joey salvia my audio editor we'll
see you on
next week's edition of just getting
started